The example here says we have a sort
of system that has three users.
The users are A, B, C,
because rows correspond to users.
And we have three resources as well,
we calling them X, Y and Z.
These are three objects
of the resources we have.
And if we look at the matrix says
well A can read write execute.
Object X can only read object Y and
has no access to object Z.
B can read write Y and
can read execute Z and things like that.
So this matrix actually tells you who
can do what given the three users and
the three sources we have.
So if you want to implement
the information that's in this access
control matrix.
Well using ACLs then we look
at what's at the top here.
So what would ACLs or
ACLs correspond to object.
So the first object is X,
first go on you find user A who
has read write execute permission.
So that's an entry in the list that
we're going to, actually in this case
the list is only going to have one
entry because B has no access, C has no
access, those are null entries that we
don't need to represent in this list.
So the ACL for X it's just going to
be this one entry which says,
user A can read, write,
and execute this object.
Still talking with ACLs, if you look
at Y, the second resource we have here.
Actually, here we're going to have three
entries in the ACL, one for each user.
A is going to be able to read it,
B can read, write it.
C can read write it, too.
Similarly for the last resource,
we're going to have two entries.
A has no access, but B and
C do, so we can read and
execute it and she can read and
execute it as well.
So this information that we have in the
access control matrix gets represented
with three access control lists.
One for each object.
This is for X, for Y, and for Z.
Now another way to represent this
very same information is to using
capability lists or C-lists.
So remember C-lists are for user.
So we have to have a C-list for user A,
one for user B, and one for user C.
If you look at A,
it has access to both X and Y.
So the C-list would have two entries.
If user A has access for resource X and
the access rights
are read write execute.
Similarly user A can read resource Y.
So this is the C-list of user A.
Similarly C-list for
user B is going to be no access for
resource X, so nothing for X.
But for Y we're going to have read
write access and similarly for
Z we're going to have
read execute access.
So this C-list is going
to have two entries.
And the C-list is going to look
the same for user C because B and
C have same kind of access.
The given set of resources
that we have here.
ACLs, you go vertical per resource.
C-list, you go horizontal or
row-wise per user, so
we are talking about how you
implement an Access Control Matrix.
Well, one way is to define or
have this list that we have, and
we'll talk about where these lists get
stored or maintained, but the ACL or
ACM information gets captured
either in ACLs or in C-lists.